Disney's latest animated movie takes us to
the mammal-centric city of Zootopia, where
a con-artist fox and a rabbit rookie cop team
up to crack a mysterious case of missing mammals.
I'm Jan and this is 25 fun facts you probably
didn't know about Zootopia.
To get inspiration for the character of rookie
rabbit police officer Judy Hopps, the filmmakers
not only visited a wildlife rescue centre,
they even had live rabbits in the studio!
And observing those real-life rabbits really
did help the animators, for example, they
noticed how rabbits' ears often turn towards
a sound before they do and how and when their
noses twitch.
For the outfits Judy wears, the animators
took cues from survivalist gear, the kind
of clothes worn by Navy SEALs, as well as
leg protection worn by racehorses.
As for the violet colour of Judy's eyes, that
was actually chosen after the animators decided
Judy's grey fur was too dull and needed a
little purple adding to make it pop so it
reflected Judy's sparky personality.
When they were creating the character of scam-artist
fox Nick Wilde, the filmmakers were inspired
by actor Cary Grant, and for Judy Hopps they
channelled characters such as Superman and
Leslie Knope from TV comedy Parks and Recreation.
Although voice actors for animated movies
typically record their parts separately, for
their lead roles as Judy Hopps and Nick Wilde,
Once Upon A Time star Ginnifer Goodwin and
Horrible Bosses star Jason Bateman recorded
as much of their dialogue as possible together
which helped them get great chemistry between
their characters.
As a reference to help them animate the scene
where Nick Wilde tries to eat a teeny tiny
piece of cake, the artists filmed Disney and
Pixar Chief Creative Officer John Lasseter
using a tiny fork to eat a very small slice
of cake off a little coin!
After meeting pop star Shakira who plays Zootopia's
own pop star Gazelle, the animators made revisions
to the design of her character.
For example, Shakira suggested that Gazelle
should be curvier, so the artists made her
hips bigger.
They also made Gazelle's eyes darker, her
lashes longer, her hair wavier, and gave her
an outfit similar to one Shakira wore for
one of her performances.
Officer Benjamin Clawhauser was initially
going to be called Hugo and some original
concept art shows him wearing an Hawaiian
shirt very similar to the one Nick Wilde wears
in the final movie.
The filmmakers wanted to make sure that each
of the movie's animals was based on their
real-world behaviour.
So, they spent 18 months researching a variety
of animals, finding out how they interact,
socialise, and build communities in the wild.
They spoke to experts from all over the world
and visited Disney's Animal Kingdom, San Diego
Zoo Safari Park, and the Natural History Museum
of Los Angeles County.
And they even spent two weeks in Kenya learning
all about animal personality and behaviour.
The filmmakers' research also helped them
decide which roles to give to each animal
in the world of Zootopia.
For example, they found out that cape buffaloes
are tough and relentless, so they opted to
make Zootopia's chief of police a buffalo.
During their trip to Africa, the filmmakers
noticed that whenever they drove by a herd
of buffaloes, the buffaloes would stop what
they were doing and fix them with their gaze.
That gave the animators the idea to give Chief
Bogo that same stare when he looks at Nick
Wilde.
The filmmakers named the head of the Zootopia
Police Department Chief Bogo after the Swahili
word m'bogo which means cape buffalo.
According to Art director Cory Loftis, when
they were designing Bogo, the filmmakers researched
police officers who are also bodybuilders
and discovered that they could not fasten
the top button on their shirts, so they took
that idea for Chief Bogo.
Because Assistant Mayor Bellwether is a sheep,
the animators decided that all of her six
outfits should be made of wool!
And on her orange skirt, you'll even spot
a scissor pattern, which represents shears!
For the scene where Nick Wilde touches the
big tuft of wool on Bellwether's head to see
how soft it is, the artists had to create
new technology as touching fur is normally
something they tend to avoid as it's especially
complex in computer-generated animation.
Speaking of fur, each mouse you see in Zootopia
has around 400,000 strands of hair, which
is the same number of strands that made up
Elsa's hair in Frozen!
And, in case you're wondering what that means
for the larger animals, well, a giraffe has
9.2 million hairs!
For the design of Mayor Leodore Lionheart,
the animators took inspiration from Mufasa
in Disney's The Lion King.
And they used technology they'd developed
when making Frozen to animate his huge mane
of hair.
The clothes worn by the Ottertons are another
example of the level of detail the animators
went to when they were designing the animals'
outfits in the movie.
The Ottertons wear thick fisherman-knit sweaters
with little fish on them.
Early on in the animation process, Disney
story artist Raymond Persi recorded a temporary
voice track for the character of Flash, who
works at the DMV, aka the Department of Mammal
Vehicles.
But the filmmakers and Chief Creative Officer
John Lasseter loved Persi's performance so
much that they decided to keep it for the
final film.
According to the filmmakers, to design Zootopia,
they had to 'think like animals'!
In other words, because the city of Zootopia
was built by the animals who live there, the
animators began by asking themselves, given
the same technology and knowledge as humans,
what would a mammal metropolis look like if
it were made by animals?!
The design of cities from around the world
also inspired the animators.
As well as looking to New York and London,
artists were equally inspired by Russian architecture,
which you can see in the onion-shaped domes
of Tundratown.
And Madrid's Atocha railway station was the
inspiration behind the interior tropical garden
at Zootopia's train station.
The idea for Sahara Square, which contains
sand dunes as well as buildings shaped like
sand dunes, was influenced by Monte Carlo
and Dubai.
Because many desert animals are nocturnal,
the animators designed lots of night-time
activities such as casinos as well as a huge
palm-tree hotel with an oasis around it.
Savanna Central, which is Zootopia's central
hub and home to the city's police department,
train station and city hall, was partly based
on Disneyland's hub-and-spoke design.
Advances in technology allowed the filmmakers
to create incredibly detailed environments
including over 500,000 trees in the city's
Rain Forest District, each of which has around
30,000 leaves on it!
Now, who's your favourite character in Zootopia
and why?
And what are your favourite Disney movies?
Tell me in the comments below!
So, guys, if you liked this video, do also
check out my Zootopia movie review here and
I'll have an Easter Eggs video here shortly.
I always appreciate your likes, shares, and
comments on my videos.
And if you fancy loads more Disney and Pixar
videos, do please subscribe!
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!